voici Naya Arthur Dali Anka Bécaud
effraya ils ont tous un point commun ils
adorent les gâteries en ce moment à
triplement sur le choix
de poulet ou alors au foie de bœuf
déshydratée
[Musique]
rendez-vous au hot-dog et compagnie à
Brossard avec nos goutteurs
professionnels la pandémie et la permis
l'augmentation de cette offre-là parce
que les gens ils ont adopté plus
d'animaux une tendance amorcer depuis
quelques années de 2016 à 2021 les
ventes de gâterie pour chien ont
augmenté de près de 40%
ici on a une fraction minime fraction de
l'offre qu'on peut trouver en magasin le
vétérinaire Younes shorty s'intéresse
depuis des années à l’alimentation de
nos animaux de compagnie on peut trouver
plusieurs types de gâteries des guêtres
végétariennes des gâteries qui peuvent
être à base de biscuits j'ai envie de
commencer par le grand-père des gâteries
et Big Bang qu'on connaît tous depuis
longtemps est-ce que ce produit là c'est
fait déclassé par tout cela
mais c'est c'est une gâterie qui est de
bonne qualité qu'on peut offrir puis les
animaux aiment ça qu'est-ce que les
chiens aiment surtout les chiens c'est
des omnivores comme nous donc ils ont un
petit peu la danse crée donc
certainement les choses qui sont sucrées
un bon weekend ou qu'il y a saveur de
beckenie va attirer plus un animal que
un simple biscuit qui qui ne sent pas
grand chose comment vous décririez la
différence entre une gâterie pour chien
et une nourriture conventionnelle
elle est complète et équilibrée pour
répondre aux besoins de l'animal ces
besoins énergétiques ses besoins de
protéiques etc la gâterie n'a pas cette
cette obligation là pour la règle est
toujours de rester à l'intérieur de 10 %
des quantités d'énergie que l'animal
doit consommer si on reste là dedans on
peut donner toutes ces gâteries là pour
des animaux qui sont en santé sur
certains emballages on vous aide à
calculer le nombre de batteries à donner
à votre chien en fonction de son poids
c'est rare que s'arrête à deux gâteries
par jour c'est difficile c'est très
difficile mais il faut absolument être
sérieux et être un petit peu plus
exigeant là-dessus parce que on a une
épidémie d'obésité au niveau de nos
chiens des chats en Amérique du Nord
parce que les Espagnols c'est des chiens
qui peuvent devenir
[Musique]
obèses facilement je donne des
récompenser est-ce que tu lui donnes des
gâteries une fois de temps en temps
quand on va le premier pour la prendre à
retirer ou à s'asseoir au bord des
trottoirs souvent quand on va apprendre
des marches on peut la prendre des
petites des petits tours c'est là qu'on
la récompense avec les gâteries
[Musique]
Oswald est très heureux d'aller
rencontrer Marion des marcheliers
experte en comportement animal
des chiens qui ont des gros problèmes de
comportement donc il faut une motivation
extraordinaire et ce qui marche chez
l'immense majorité c'est le foie de bœuf
séché c'est bien parce que c'est sec
donc ça se coupe en toute petite miettes
et c'est quelque chose qui est assez
universellement pour les chiens qui n'y
sont pas allergiques fonctionnent
extrêmement bien il savait pas dire que
toute la vie du chien à chaque fois
qu'il s'assoit on va devoir lui en
donner une fois que le comportement est
acquis il le sait il le fait si on lui
demande moi les gatry que je recommande
en général à tout le monde c'est des
choses qu'on peut couper en très petit
pour l'entraînement parce que on veut
pouvoir récompenser souvent et donc on
veut pas non plus leur randonner des
grosses quantités parce qu'après ils
seront plus motivés etc est-ce que je
pourrais lui donner une croquette de sa
nourriture régulière et pas
nécessairement une friandise une gâterie
si ça marche oui mais si ça marche pas
non encore une fois il faut trouver la
bonne gatrie pour le bon moment
il y a des choses pour lesquelles il
faut absolument être vigilant et
surveiller c'est la quantité de gras qui
est dans la gâterie si on a un 20% de
grâce à ça ça marche pas là c'est il
faut aller à des pourcentages qui sont
vraiment vraiment très bas pour qu'on
puisse offrir ce type de gâterie à notre
animal
référez-vous à l'analyse garantie
l'équivalent de notre tableau de valeur
nutritive
on a ici un produit qui est bon pour les
soins bucco-dentaires quotidien ce sont
des gâtés qui généralement ils vont
mimer le brossage donc l'animal il va
travailler un petit peu il va gruger ça
permet certainement d'améliorer la
qualité dentaire de ses animaux
les gars triangles en cuir ont aussi un
effet bénéfique sur la santé dentaire
[Musique]
de plus en plus il y a une offre santé
où on offre des suppléments ici le
hanche est articulations avec
glucosamine et MSM ça ne nuit pas donc
ça peut aider un petit peu un animal qui
est des problèmes de douleur
articulaires donc des animaux qui ont
des problèmes à reposer donc c'est ça si
on donne 10% de la peur alimentaire en
gâterie faut pas s'attendre de grands
miracles absolument pas mais ça
contribue à donc c'est un peu ça
l'objectif aussi on a même trouvé des
gâteries à base de Grillon les protéines
de grillons sont des protéines très
similaires sinon parfois supérieurs à
ceux de poulet
autant l'offre et diversifiée autant les
prix le son certaines gâteries se
vendent aussi cher que quatre fois le
prix du filet mignon
celui-ci est à 33 dollars le 100 g
celui-ci environ un dollar le 100 g
qu'on peut acheter au Dollarama lequel
vous privilégiez il faut absolument voir
les ingrédients sur l'étiquette il vient
de la Nouvelle-Zélande et ce sont des
tripes d'agneau ça veut dire que c'est
100% de l'agneau et puisque la protéine
c'est elle qui coûte le plus cher dans
une nourriture dans une gâterie mais on
peut justifier un peu pourquoi le prix
est très élevé si on regarde celui-là
c'est écrit fois de poulet frais et
quand on regarde la liste des
ingrédients le foie de poulet il est au
9e rang donc ça justifie un peu pourquoi
le prix est trop bas
les gâteries il faut en donner les gens
aiment le donner les animaux et ils
adorent ça aussi ça permet d'augmenter
ce lien là d'affection entre l'humain et
son compagnon par contre on n'est pas
obligé de dépenser beaucoup par rapport
à des de donner très bien des fruits et
des légumes que l'animal il va il va
accepter l'essentiel c'est le geste de
donner qui est le plus important
et ici
c'est une qualité humaine est-ce que ça
veut dire qu'on pourrait se faire un
petit sac on va l'essayer qualité
humaine
[Musique]
c'est pas pire mais je le mangerai pas
chaque jour
[Musique]